hello and welcome to a brief clip from
gamespot of thrones if you'd like to
watch the full episode head over to
youtube.com slash GameSpot but if you
keep watching here then please be aware
of spoilers all right season six it's
over what were our favorite bits let's
start with those tomorrow I think for me
it was the the big moment for me was
Daenerys the unburnt as she's been
called online vol 2 yeah mother of
dragons breaker of chains queen of the
Andals in the Seven Kingdoms I'd like to
add you to my professional network by
the last two seasons most of season 6
and the entirety of season 5 I'd say
well spent taking power away from her
and so like for for the last half of
this this season we finally got to see
her becoming Khaleesi once again and
kind of taking that back she spent all
this time freeing slaves and you know
fighting these oppressors and being a
generally good person and then she kind
of hit a wall at one point I was like
well now I'm gonna get kidnapped and now
I'm gonna get stuck with these Dothraki
for ages like what's going on it was
almost as if like she was moving too
fast for the rest of the story like
everyone else needed to get to a point
where you know they they were good for
her to come over and be like all right
guys I'm gonna sort this stuff out now
but she went a bit too far so they kind
of had to leave her in a kidnapped
position for a little while but she took
care of business she took out the you
know Dothraki got her dragons back on
side and now is ready to roll again it's
that powerful feeling like everyone's
okay everyone online is like yes
Khaleesi is back cuz in the book when
like Daenerys is interim 'but just goes
on forever
it's just sat in marine like the whole
marriage stuff to fight it the bloody
fighting pits
yes I'm really glad she got somewhere
this year she's earned her title of
Khaleesi back again
finally
and then I can't I don't think we can
mention things we loved without the love
that we all want to happen
Giants Bay the moment that those two met
eyes and tormund's eyes just dropped it
felt like the moment is a bad game if I
like the moment the mask whether it was
George Rogers head but like in a game of
Thrones sense and then over like the
cause of episodes we just see him like
sneaking looks it wasn't even just
sneaking looks he'd be like raising his
eyebrows like and then like seductively
eating a chicken like laughs like he
never supposed to oh did he
it just sort of barely he kind of
breathed in a direction from across the
table like in another chicken leg we
know how much the community loves this
this little relationship and how much
they want it's happened you just don't
know you have to look at the number of
memes and Photoshop so the two together
and you know like I hope this I think I
think it's just it's it's really loved
because it was so unexpected because
they spent all this time building up
torment as this you know this fearsome
warrior that what did he like kill a
bear or something he did something bad
to a bear and like he's like this very
is the most wildling there is right he's
got a giant beard he was no yeah he's
peak wall and covered in first carries a
massive weapon and you know it's all
like rough and rugged and then sees like
this lady is like hey how's it going
it becomes like a little teenager and in
in a universe where you know people are
lusting after like characters like
Melisandre and you know and all the
lovely ladies of King's Landing
yeah and then torrents like and there's
like a charm innocence to the way they
do it right you get different types of
approaching like love interest in this
in this series you get like Littlefinger
who's like mega creepy about some people
like a bad boy I think you're taking it
too you know weird like Ben Linus was
also my favorite character on lost I'm
sensing oh we had two themed old people
so now you have those ones and you have
people are like aggressive like weird
rapey and then people like Carl Drago is
just like some
occasion but his ones like a really
innocent like looks like childlike like
schoolboy stylist gonna stop pulling her
pigtails doesn't know how to flip a
frying a tennis ball nutter and stuff
hello cute ones away here mate to go up
another moment I really really enjoyed
was the Tower of joy because what I just
I needed that resolution I was kind of
pissed that it took them like the entire
season like they went to the Tower of
joy in very early in the sea like
episode 2 and then like I get like a
foot closer to the lazy if they just
went full-on with it like open the door
in episode 1 and then episode 2 just
like end of the other seasons walk for
em in like like 20 frames in every
episode resin the evil door opening
animation over the course of 20 episodes
I see here is no but I'm just glad that
they finally finally open the door we
got they promised me nerd you got the
you know got the resolution that that
very serious-looking baby would turn
into a very serious-looking young man
and obviously they lost off that may or
may not pay off yes II did more fan
theories about either blood oh yeah the
stuff before it as well like the battle
leading up to it oh yeah you know you've
seen young Ned whoever they that dude
there they cost his young net well done
he looks like a young Neil Patrick
Harris yeah we would incredible Sean
Bean impression yeah I was a great
casting and obviously the the battle
with his buddy you know the legend that
they had read yeah yeah that was those
interesting as well but yeah it did take
a long time to pay off but it was always
gonna take a long time right that was
literally the most important thing that
they had to reveal this season and if
they did it early on a big a very it
peak too high too early and they'll be
it I never thought I'd say this but my
other favorite moment also involved bran
which is you know like branded like a
180
hearts over the course of 10 episodes
which was to hold the door because I
just thought that was it was incredibly
sad yeah but it was so well done and
just like the guys name Sam Coleman he
did an incredible job of like just that
really heartbreaking moment the hold the
door I like that moment it's very sad I
was touching but like Brian continues to
be an annoying useless little mmm yeah
he Brian keeps making so many mistakes
earning something every time he does it
I'm like Hodor sacrificed himself for
you and you're laying him down and like
I would rather have Hodor has been more
effective than bran and brands got this
like destiny to be the three-eyed Raven
his magical Ward and [ __ ] but like
Hodor has been way more effective than
you he's done way more like get rid of
you should make him the three-eyed Raven
instead he'd be badass the worst part
about that scene is that I can no longer
ask someone to hold the door and I live
ha ha ha ha
you